Today, I'm going to be speaking with Dan Kovalik,
who is a labor and human rights attorney and
also author of the book, canceled this book,
The Progressive Case Against Council Culture.
It's great to have you on down.
It's great to be here, David.
Thank you.
So the reason I'm interested in this is there
are certainly a range of views across the
political spectrum about this issue of so-called
council culture and what what counts as council
culture and what doesn't.
But even within the left, there is some disagreement
as to whether it's taking place, what counts,
what should be done.
Maybe start by kind of giving us your sense
of relative to the idea that we hear on right
wing media about this as a sort of speech
suppression, politically based epidemic that
is taking place in media and academia and
across the social and cultural areas.
How does your position compare to that as
a starting point?
Yes, to compare it to the right wing position,
I think mine is certainly different.
First of all, I'm not hysterical about it.
I mean, I, I try to deal with it in a reasoned
way.
I certainly am concerned about it.
You know, I'll just give examples like I'm
not concerned about the fact that Pepy Lupu
is not going to be in the next this movie.
Yeah.
That was decided by the producers.
And, you know, I certainly think that he is
a problematic character who basically his
only thing he ever did was assault the other
skunk.
The same thing with the Dr. Seuss issue.
I mean, the state itself, apparently, of Dr.
Seuss decided to get rid of these six books,
which no one ever heard of and which, you
know, were offensive.
And I think Dr. Seuss.
Progressed in his thoughts as he got older.
And that actually is a good Segway into what
I am concerned about, what would concern me
is if all of Dr. Seuss's books were canceled
because of his earlier works.
OK, the concern I have about.
Cancer culture, particularly on the left,
is that it seems to me there's a lack of forgiveness
and and chance for redemption for people.
You make one mistake and I've seen this, all
of us have seen this many times.
And that's why people who deny the cancer
culture exist.
I just think we're not being honest.
We see many times someone will do something
that is offensive or barely offensive or seen
by someone is offensive and they're immediately
shut out.
People call for them to be fired.
Sometimes they'll get fired.
That concerns me.
So let's break down that process so that we
can maybe even figure out which is the part
that concerns you, because so let's imagine
a situation where someone tweets something
that we agree is offensive, not related to
their work while they are on the weekend.
Or, you know, there was this story that Jon
Ronson talks about in his book.
So you've been publicly shamed, a woman who
tweeted something about white versus black
people getting AIDS as she stepped onto a
flight.
And then when she landed and it exploded into
an international story and photographers were
waiting for her and whatever.
OK, so the thing is said then there is a public
outcry from people who say this is bad.
Sometimes you'll see the public contact the
employer of the individual and ask for them
to be fired.
Even if what was said does does arguably not
directly relate to the person's job, the employer
will then sometimes put out a statement.
Sometimes they'll say, we are disciplining
the person.
Sometimes they will fire the person.
Now, at every individual level, people tweeting
outrage seems to be something that I don't
have a problem with.
People tweeting outrage, people demanding
that the person be fired is a question mark
for me.
And this this has been done to me before,
in fact, as well, in the sense that certainly
calling a business, if you find out the person
works somewhere and you're going to say if
this person works for you, I'm not going to
be a patron of your business, certainly something
I can't say is wrong to do, although I might
disagree with it.
And then the firing decision.
An employer can decide as long as they're
not discriminating on the basis of protected
class, it's no longer good for our business
to have this person working for us.
So like the pieces all when you break them
down, the way I'm doing it aren't particularly
concerning.
So, like, which aspect is that you are most
worried about?
Well, first of all, I mean, the context is
everything.
And I mean, it's one thing if you just if
you find out someone is an avowed white supremacist,
OK, at night, dresses up in a hood and is
part of the Ku Klux Klan.
This is a person with bad motives, bad intentions.
I think how you deal with that person would
be different than someone who who is otherwise
well-intentioned, who says something inadvertently,
you're offensive or does something inadvertently
offensive.
I think they need to be treated differently.
I don't think you should pile on someone,
even on social media who makes a mistake and
who says, look, I'm sorry.
Right?
And that happens a lot.
Right.
And usually even after the I'm sorry, it doesn't
end right.
And I certainly don't think you should try
to get someone like that fired except in the
most egregious circumstance.
I don't see getting someone fired in most
circumstances, some act of social activism.
I see it as something counter to solidarity
with your fellow workers, with your fellow
comrades.
Many times in this concerns me greatly, especially
in the academy now.
And I talk about this in my book.
I think a lot of people don't understand that
the academy has gone through a huge transformation
in recent decades from tenured professors
on the most part to now adjunct professor.
Most professors now are adjunct.
What does that mean?
Means they don't have tenure, the right job
security.
They get paid poverty wages.
I'm an adjunct.
For example, I get three thousand dollars
per class.
I teach at the law school.
I may teach 50 students to pay 40 grand a
year to attend it.
Right.
And I get three grand for the whole class
and can be fired mid semester.
I have no you know, I'm basically a glorified,
you know, gig worker.
Right, right.
Yeah.
And I've taught adjunct as well at Boston
College and I've had a similar experience.
And to call lightly and I think many times
it's slightly for someone like that to be
fired.
Is kicking down.
It's not punching up, it's not fighting, you're
not taking on the man, in fact, I agree with
you.
He is uniting with the man, right?
The administrators who make a lot of money,
hundreds of thousands of dollars, if not over
a million against these lowly adjuncts.
And you see this.
A lot,
yeah, a woman named Amy Siskind, a Democratic
activist, tried to get me fired for from Boston
College because I responded to a tweet of
hers saying that the 20 20 nominee or maybe
it was even 2016, 2020 shouldn't be white
or a man.
And I said, that seems to me to be wrong to
to disqualify someone on the basis of sex
or race.
And she tried to get me fired from Boston
College.
And that's wrong.
But what I'm hearing from you is more that
you just think sometimes these tools are wielded
when they shouldn't be like there is more
egregious and less egregious cases.
And sometimes you just think the action doesn't
rise to warranting a call to be fired.
For example,
I think it would be a rare case where that
would be legitimate.
Let me put it that way.
But I do think there's something that people
now refer to the Overton Window.
Yes, you've probably heard that, that there
is a line.
There are lines of demarcation.
Again, I think if someone is an avowed racist,
an avowed white supremacist, you know, particularly
in a sensitive position of power, I think
it's legitimate to call that person out publicly
and with their employer.
But who gets to who gets to decide what rises
to what level?
And the position is sensitive.
Well, that's a great question.
I mean, I think obviously it's up to the individual
who's doing the attempted counseling, if we
want to say that, OK, has to use some judgment.
But I think giving what I'm illustrating is
that you would do this very rarely.
You know, there's you know, not that many.
There are obviously avowed white supremacists.
But, you know, most of the people we come
in contact with on a daily basis are not that.
And in most of the people that are being canceled
are not that.
In fact, you know, the irony is to calling
someone a racist or sexist is only damaging
to people who don't want to be racist or sexist.
Right.
I mean, if you're an avowed racist, that's
a compliment, I guess.
So what would be what would be an example
of someone who was called a racist and then
fired?
But what they said was just a lapse in judgment
and really they shouldn't have been.
OK, well, I'll give an example from my book
and why I wrote the book because of something
that happened in Pittsburgh in this was not
someone who was fired, but in a way, it was
it was even greater than being fired.
So in Pittsburgh, we have this peace and justice
group called the Thomas Merton Center, and
it was founded 50 years ago, co-founded by
someone named Molly Rush, a long time peace
activist and also someone who's advocated
for economic and racial justice during the
George FOID protest of last summer, she posted
on Facebook, reposted.
Someone had posted it and she just hit share,
which many of us do without thinking.
She posted this meme with a picture of Martin
Luther King and it said, Never rioted, never
looted.
Change the world.
Immediately, people started jumping on her
on Facebook, attacking her as a racist, attacking
her family who defended her, calling them
white trash.
She apologized on Facebook publicly, but that
wasn't enough.
What what ended up happening happening is
the Thomas Merton Center, the board of the
Thomas Merton Center, put out a letter.
Both to all Thomas Merton Center members and
publicly on Facebook, saying they could no
longer work with Molly Rush.
Yeah, after 50 years.
And this is, you know, so the argument was
this meme was racist because you shouldn't
tell African-Americans how to fight for their
liberation, right?
If if there's some violence that ensues, it's
not for us to say.
And of course, though, as I point out in my
book.
If you look at a lot of the violence that
happened, a lot of it.
Probably the vast majority was not done by
African-Americans, it was done either by young
white anarchists, usually young white males
or young white male right wingers trying to
either inflame the situation or to delegitimize
Black Lives Matter.
So calling those people out.
Why is that problematic, in fact, in Portland,
as I mentioned, there were newspaper articles
that quoted people from Black Lives Matter
and from the NAACP saying that the violence
that took place night after night in Portland
and around midnight and later had nothing
to do with Black Lives Matter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Something else.
This was, again, young white people who were
anarchists or whatever they were who decided
they wanted to do what they wanted to do,
which was attack the federal courthouse night
after night.
I think this is a great example.
I mean, listen, if this example is as you
describe it, and I have no reason to doubt
it, I'm just saying I'm what I know about
it is what you're telling me exactly.
This would be one where I agree this this
sounds like the wrong solution.
But in a I guess where I worry is that in
a country of three hundred and thirty one
million people, there is examples of everything.
Every good company that's a big company is
going to have one hundred or a thousand customer
experiences that sound terrible, but they
represent very little in the scope of the
how the company deals with customers.
As an example, you know, I worry that the
this is being called an epidemic when I will
grant that in a country of three hundred and
thirty one million.
The example just you gave me sounds terrible.
It sounds completely counterproductive to
the goals of me as a person on the left, for
example.
And I'm with you.
If the details are as described, I just don't
see the epidemic.
And individually, it sounds like you certainly
defend the people, the right of people to
express their distaste on social media.
Right.
Like you and I are on the same page there.
Yes, absolutely.
And you certainly defend the right of individuals
to tell a company I won't do business with
you because of this, whether they're right
or wrong, you defend the right that they have
to do that.
Well, certainly consumers have that right.
They certainly have that legal right.
They should.
Yeah.
Again, it's a matter of discretion.
Sure.
Whether or a matter of conscience, whether
they should do it, that's another question.
But.
Right.
People have the legal right to do that.
And then businesses as far as businesses that
exist, some are regulated in certain ways
and some some are others.
As long as they're not breaking any laws,
they can also decide having a certain employee
is bad for us and it could hurt profits or
whatever.
We don't want this employee working for us
that you agree with.
Yes, of course.
So it sounds like really it's the sometimes
overbearing activation of these tactics that
you're concerned about.
Well, yes.
And again, I never use the word epidemic in
my book or when I talk about this.
Yeah.
And I wouldn't use that.
But I do think it is I think it is a frequent
use tactic against people, particularly in
the academy.
The academies really soaked in
this stuff.
Let's pause our conversation there
with Daniel Kovalik, author of
Canceled
this book, The Progressive Case Against Council
Culture.
The full interview will be on The David Pakman
Show YouTube channel
at YouTube.
Dotcom slash
The David Pakman Show